When you guys can really play.
Hi everybody. I'm Marin Alsop.
Marin began conducting in 1980.
She's currently the chief conductor of the Vienna radio symphony orchestra.
Today I'll be breaking down clips from movies and TV about
orchestras technique, Mr. Holland's Opus,
When he starts the piece,
it looks as though it's going to be a very quiet opening. Certainly not.
That could be good to get in the drums.
You really have to set up the drums in a much bigger way.
[Inaudible].
Another big issue I have with this clip is that I can't
imagine any student orchestra playing at this level,
the high trumpets, the horns.
[Inaudible] the articulation
[inaudible].
This is way, way,
way beyond a high school orchestra could possibly play.
[Inaudible].
The character of Mr. Holland. He's basically just beating time.
It's a very robotic approach to conducting with both arms doing the
exact same thing.
[Inaudible].
And this is one of the basic conducting
issues that we try to discourage our students from doing.
We're not hearing press each other.
Inducting is all about separating your hands so that you can create
two different worlds. The right hand controls the pulse, the beat,
and has to be in a pattern a for pattern two, three, four,
a three, pattern one, two, three or two pattern.
And the left hand is all about emotion, about gesture,
about dynamics. This is getting louder. This is getting softer.
There's a lot that the musicians read from our faces,
but mostly it's working on this independence of hands,
which he doesn't exhibit whatsoever in this clip.
[Inaudible].
I know that this is a sort of a very empowering and
emotional scene,
But from watching his gestures,
we really wouldn't know that.
Lingo.
On DAS gum.
Must be good.
The lingo.
Used here is a of two things.
One is the text for the Requiem mass,
and this is from the Latin text for the mass.
And the section that they're working on is the confluent. The,
so that's actually the lyric that Mozart is composing it that way.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes. Go on VOCA may sort of vote. You
write that down sort of a chase. Yes. Yes.
When Mozart asks Sally airy to please write in SOTA vote, Jane,
that's an Italian instruction that composers
use to describe the quality of the sound.
And so to vote chain means under voice.
So it's almost like whispering.
And on Dictus yes. And underneath just violins arpeggios.
Or the other term arpeggio that's when the
orchestration outlines the triads outlines,
the notes bought off.
[Inaudible].
Sending stealing eighth notes and then back to the astronaut or again.
That's an arpeggio trumpets and D don't listen to me.
I don't understand when Sally Arie says, I don't understand.
I don't think that's realistic. He would have definitely understood.
You don't understand.
The director is trying to point out how advanced Mozart was.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes. Go on. I absolutely love this movie.
It's historically not 100% accurate. It's not to be believed,
but it so captures the immense talent
of Mozart. Thank you.
And the sense that he knew what he wanted to write,
and he could just put it right into the full score, just out of his head.
Taking the patient music in his head, motivation,
whiplash,
where you rushing or where you drunk.
You know,
I can barely discern that he's rushing ever so
slightly, But you know, often musicians,
they need a little bit of runway to get into the groove of a piece,
especially young musicians.
The teacher has absolutely no tolerance for any kind of imperfection.
Five, six, seven, four. Look at me. One, two, three, four, one,
two, three, four.
I think this kind of approach, you know, where you break,
where a teacher breaks a student and then remold them and
rebuild them in, in kind of in their image.
It's a very self-centered narcissistic way
of teaching.
It can be effective because it's terrifying,
but I don't think people learn.
Fear, start practicing harder. And Damon
whiplash bar one 25.
I think business is highly competitive.
It's not unusual in a student setting to have competitions
for the first chair. So, you know, this can be either a,
an extremely productive and positive experience or it can be
like it is in whiplash. It can be a competition almost to the death.
Why are you still sitting there? Get the out novice conductor,
Mr. Bean.
When I start the opening of Beethoven's fifth symphony,
[inaudible] always have to be very careful not to make a gesture before that
opening gesture, because somebody will play
And that's, what's so cute about this. It makes me laugh out loud.
He just moves the Baton and he gets a cord box.
First time conductor. I definitely give him high marks.
He understands the idea of body language and response,
and that's what comes across.
So clearly in this little clip conducting a choir
sister act.
[Inaudible].
First of all, I have to say, I love her enthusiasm.
You'll notice in this clip and it's quite realistic that Whoopi doesn't use any
Baton. She uses just her hands.
This is quite typical of choir conductors.
It's more about dictating what's happening and really describing it
with your, with both hands,
as opposed to very elaborate patterns and trying to give
cues to everyone.
[Inaudible].
This is a much more visceral kind of approach to conducting.
And I find that with choirs, it really works well.
[Inaudible].
Absolutely adore what be Goldberg.
I think she's phenomenal in this role,
this place there's so much heart in it.
And I think as a conductor, that's really what we're trying to do.
We're trying to inspire others to be the best they can be.
That's our goal
rehearsal unorthodox.
Okay.
The thing that I love about this clip is that the orchestra is really playing
the divorce string serenade.
[Inaudible].
Level that they're playing at is a level that would be consistent with a student
orchestra. Gotcha.
Where are you today? It was pointing the wrong boy.
That's not exactly what a young violinists would say.
They would say I was on the wrong bow or I was doing the wrong bowings in
essence, what it means is that someone is out of sync. Where are you today?
When one player in a section is going in opposition,
it can really upset the look of the section and the ensemble
too,
because string sections are accustomed to doing the same bowings at the
same time.
[Inaudible].
Is the main character trying to imagine herself in this
setting.
What I loved about this series is that it didn't pretend
to suddenly make a virtuoso out of someone who couldn't
possibly have achieved that level yet singers who are born with beautiful
voices,
but no one comes out of Brooklyn after a few lessons on the piano already to
play the Philharmonic. Instead,
it was much more realistic about whether she could
get into this conservatory. And if so, on what instrument?
Not that the piano, not fr I'm sorry, imitation copying Beethoven.
[Inaudible].
We see the premiere of Beethoven's final symphony,
his monumental ninth symphony.
And by this time in his life,
he was almost entirely dead.
[Inaudible].
Following the conducting of the actress in front
of him and really imitating her gestures because of course he can't
hear the orchestra and can't react to it.
[Inaudible].
It's not an easy thing to do,
to do the exact opposite of what you normally do.
I actually have played in an orchestra where someone who didn't
read music was taught to conduct in this way.
It was a very odd thing to experience,
but it was quite fascinating in a way to see this kind of
symbiotic conducting experience.
The premiere of Beethoven's ninth symphony could not have possibly
sounded this good. The piece was incredibly hard for the orchestra of that day.
They only had one day of rehearsal.
I want to say while I enjoy this clip so much,
I think that the playing is far too good. Most experienced.
These works of my conducting dancers, Mozart in the jungle.
We don't even know where this music is coming from,
but this whole scene plays into this Maestro mythology. You know,
the idea of the conductor as this magician,
this inaccessible and talented creature.
It's very mysterious that somehow can conjure up music from thin air.
I mean, of course, I don't believe this for a second.
This is not really an instance of dancers
reacting to the conductor because they clearly have their own
choreography and their own movements.
I think this whole series Mozart in the jungle has been absolutely
wonderful for classical music in terms of bringing it into our homes and
demystifying it. But it also is a bit unrealistic
relationships meeting Venus.
The orchestra work,
according to schedule agreed within the union and the management.
So it was pointless to have a real soul yesterday and it will be equally
pointless to talk about my ideas today.
I think this is a fascinating clip because it really gives you some insight into
the hierarchy of, you know, who's, who's really in charge.
Please. When we see conductors with orchestras, they are clearly, you know,
in the alpha role. But when we see conductors in the opera house,
the conductor has to contend, of course, with the musicians.
You'll be here. I don't know. I haven't looked at much how you.
You have a diva like Glenn close.
Introduced to you, Maestro something.
You have to deal with that.
The conductor is definitely on the bottom of this hierarchy,
hold Aria.
That is not something that would normally happen.
The soloist speaks with the conductor and says, what's our plan,
which will we do? And then the conductor would ask the orchestra,
please let's turn to this Aria.
I have great empathy for the character Santos.
So the conductor in this clip.
Maya's through, we weren't even here yet.
There have been situations that I've been in where Oh,
people don't show up or someone's ill and I've gone to an upper performance.
And I have a different cast in the evening from what I had at the rehearsal,
you have to somehow manage all of these
catastrophes.
Lucy, what I have to put up with souls at time. Can you shut them up?
Switching Gianna's school of rock.
[Inaudible].
In this scene,
Jack Black discovers that his students are really proficient
at classical music.
You guys can really play. Why didn't anyone tell me.
Now he wants to introduce them to rock music and make a really
fantastic band.
Two, three, four.
Cool musicians that go into rock. I think have a really fun time letting loose.
I think when rock musicians come over to classical music,
sometimes they're shocked by the rigidity of this
style of music. Nothing could be harder.
What I absolutely love about this scene and about this whole movie is Jack
Black's enthusiasm.
[Inaudible].
He's just dying to share his passion with us.
Wow.
I think that is the number one criteria for being a
conductor is to want and really insist on sharing one's
passion for the music.
Right?
It's really about capturing the groove for everything.
That's ultimately the conductor's main job is capturing that group.
So I love it. Practice the orchestra rehearsal.
[Inaudible].
It's clear that no one's playing an instrument.
Their bows are going all which ways they're playing at different times.
[inaudible], He's conducting on the wrong beat of the bar.
So there's a sense of chaos.
[Inaudible].
When the conductor is speaking while you're playing,
you can't hear what he's saying or she is.
[Inaudible].
I've certainly never had musicians disrobe down to the skin in rehearsals.
[Inaudible] Namaste. [inaudible].
He's trying to catch someone out and really
reprimand them in front of the entire orchestra, which I think is,
is inappropriate under any circumstance.
[Inaudible].
I think there's no turning back for this conductor. At this point,
the point of this film is the individual characters,
and it's the idea of the individual revolting
against the establishment, which is represented by the conductor.
This isn't a highly political film and it's about much more
than an orchestra rehearsal,
Wrong note, Hannibal red dragon.
[Inaudible].
Hannibal goes to the concert hall and listens to a performance of Mendelssohn's
Midsummer night's, dream.
[Inaudible].
And he notices a few problems in the orchestra.
People make mistakes. And I think it's important as the conductor to notice it,
of course,
but how the conductor reacts can really impact
the, the entire piece from there. On.
As soon.
As you start to kind of reprimand with your face,
all the musicians start to go down this path.
It can be like a domino effect that everyone starts playing wrong.
Those are everyone starts having errors.
[Inaudible].
I think if I were a musician in the orchestra and I looked out and I saw
Hannibal sitting in the audience,
I wouldn't have a bad day and play wrong notes to conclusion.
This was a wonderful experience to look at all of these clips and analyze them.
It made me realize what a metaphor music is and how much we
connect with it on so many levels.